but the gemstones the righteous
gemstones your amber gemstone you're
you're playing in a with a legendary
cast with john goodman and danny mcbride
you're danny mcbride's wife amber um i
haven't watched all of it i've watched
two episodes i i was kind of just blown
away it's just kind of
absolutely
nuts and i understand what you say when
it's like you get a little bit it's
overwhelming sometimes and all these
people who their minds just keep going
and keep going and you're trying to play
catch-up um what is that paint the
picture where you're in a scene and
everybody's improvising what do you do
do you try to step up and you're trying
to be on their level you're just like
know your lines know the scene know
where it's going and just just react
listen and react what do you do
um because you never know what's coming
at you with danny mcbride
you don't you don't no you don't and i
love that
um
this is it isn't it is an incredible
cast of people to be working with i feel
so lucky i have by the way i have to be
honest with you i'm gonna i'm only
cutting you off for a second then i want
you to continue
when i watch it i i love john goodman
he's one of my favorites of all time
he's just a brilliant actor but when i
see him on this set in the hot
charleston south carolina i have to
imagine he's the biggest pain in the ass
in the world and wants to be upset like
i could just imagine him wanting to like
going get me off the set are we done
here
no no he's so he's the opposite he is
thank god i thought for sure he'd be
miserable
no we're always worried we're like are
we gonna really are we gonna give john
heat stroke are we like what's happening
because he won't leave set he'll be like
no let's do it again let's do it again
and someone will be like let's rest in
the cooling tent and that's like you
know
have a drink of water good no let's go
like he's so
he's so dedicated he's really hard on
himself in a really
like
in interesting way i don't want to say
cute or adore like i i i like it because
i identify with it someone who holds
themselves to high standards i think you
probably can too given our conversation
right
um he's not at all he is he is such a
team player uh almost to a fault
almost almost sometimes too
to all of us because because we you know
those are very hot days and this season
in particular which we just started
shooting i just had my first week of
work
last week um
we started the season in june so it is a
scorcher out there
um they by the way
what do you do though what do you like
how do you know first off how do you not
laugh well finish your thought dan i'm
sorry finish your thought on
the improv and it's all around you and
people are throwing [ __ ] around you and
what are you feeling like
yeah look if look if i
that's a good question and what do i do
in that moment because there have been
other interviewers or people who have
kind of described amber specifically
actually eli and amber as sort of
meaning john goodman's character being
the the straight people in like a wacky
world um
i actually think amber's wacky in her
own way but she's not the same kind of
wacky so if it was if cassidy was doing
an improv with edie and danny and adam
and tim and you know that would be i
would maybe act differently but amber is
not trying to one-up amber is uh she
watches and then she makes like these
strikes whenever she calculating
yes she's calculating that's a great
that's a great word